today on stick to football Connors back
and baby we are breaking down everything
that happened over the weekend with the
NFL trades we're gonna grade every move
that happened like true bleacher report
style we're gonna put some grades on
things we're gonna talk about who
impressed week one accountable as it
affects the NFL Draft and then we're
gonna go through week one NFL picking
these games against the spread it's
gonna be a ton of fun but Connor welcome
back from Nashville man oh man now I
know why you go there so much good lord
man that place is out of control I was
saying I spent 12 my last 15 days in
Vegas or Nashville and it's it's good to
be back in New York doing the show and
god it was crazy so much went on because
obviously college football full slate of
games and all these trades Matt that we
have to talk about before we even get to
the trades though the cowboy sign extend
another player that is not named Ezekiel
Elliott
yeah Lyle Collins in good for Lyla
Collins he comes in and a deal that is
pretty team friendly I know you're gonna
see things like oh he got the highest
guarantee ever for a right tackle do you
remember a couple shows ago I was like
this is what they need to do is he just
give him the highest guaranteed money
make it you know a front loaded deal
this is what they basically double al
Collins and by doing this they create
cap room they create almost six million
dollars in cap room I wonder who they're
gonna use that money on I bet it's the
guy flying home from Cabo today yeah I
think so too I think they're gonna get
this thing done with Ezekiel Elliott
before the season kicks off thank God
the Cowboys will be in full swing I do
think at the end of the day Matt this
one's a little bit surprising the
thirty-five million dollars guaranteed
to Lyle Collins I believe will make him
now a top five paid offensive tackle in
the league now these numbers get you
know blown out of the water year after
year either month after month sometimes
but I think a lot of people did not
expect him to be there for the long term
this is great for Dallas and I think it
leads us to a really big question
besides Ezekiel Elliott situation is who
is gonna be the odd man out of this
wonderful Dallas Cowboys core to not get
an extension I think when you look at it
the one thing that stands out to me I
know a lot of people and I've probably
said it at some point too when you look
at okay Jaylon Smith
extended lakhan's getting extended it
does make you wonder is there room for
Zeke is there room for dak is there room
for a Mari I think there is I think
there's gonna be room for Byron Jones I
think it's gonna be those those guys on
the periphery the offensive line is
locked up through 2023 those guys are
set they're solid but when you look at
okay we're where the cuts gonna come I
think Byron Jones is probably gonna
price him out of Dallas's range just
because of how talented he is on the
back end the need for the position at
corner and and the fact that this was a
former first-round pick he's gonna want
big money because he has played well so
when I look at Dallas that's where I
start to see like oh man there I if I
reading the tea leaves correctly here I
would expect their 2020 draft to be
heavily influenced by the defensive back
group and then the wide receiver group
because those are the two areas where
they're gonna be able to keep Cooper but
you know guys like Randall Cobb table in
Austin they don't have a solid number
too unless Michael Gallup takes a big
step forward so on the outside looking
in I really do think it probably starts
with Byron Jones and then you know
you're looking at guys like you know
taco Charlton really hasn't panned out
Malik Collins it's just okay those are
the types of young guys that I don't
think you factor into your long-term
plan yeah I'm with you there and I think
you know maybe Tyron Smith will take
somewhat of a pay cut depending on how
his health is that'll be an interesting
one to watch because he has so much
money in the future great player great
player but maybe they've restructure
some salaries around a little bit and
Wilma clay is one of the best the
overall scouting you know his head
Scouts in the NFL he obviously runs all
their drafts there in Dallas I think
McCoy is probably already looking at
next year's class it's a very deep
corner group Dallas has corners in
defensive backs behind Byron Jones
they're probably looking at the
situation and saying hey we need to get
our premium guys in jail and Lyle then
that you know the triplets there that
they have with dacum are E&Z got to get
them done we'll figure out the rest in
the future going forward so I actually
really really like what Dallas has done
here I did too and it's one of those
things where I think you can be
confusing when the first move comes in
you're like okay what what are they
doing here signing Jaylon Smith but now
it does make sense especially with Lyla
Khan it's actually create
cap space for them and I will credit
Jerry and Steven Jones and Wilma Claire
they've done a great job I also think
it's cool that they take two guys in
Jalen Lal who fell in the draft they
were both top 20 picks locks as top 20
yes and their respective drafts they
both fell due to circumstances outside
their control now they both get rewarded
with early deals and we've seen this
with Collins it's actually his second
extension so we've seen that with him
before but now we see it with Jalen to
where these guys get a chance to make up
early some of the money they lost by
falling in the draft
yeah Dallas is sitting at the poker
table in these last couple giraffes and
they're not walking up with $5 bills
they're walking up with a hundred five
hundred dollars and they're playing big
hands and guess what right now they're
winning because of those big hands so
you take a risk like Jaylon Smith who
had health concerns
Lyle Collins who one of the you know
craziest draft stories or draft slides
we've seen in recent years and they come
out big winners so good for the players
good for the Cowboys and I think this
should make the Dallas Cowboy fan feel
very good right now it absolutely should
one fan base that maybe should not feel
great is the Los Angeles chargers and
that's because the charges of Tom
telesco they did what we said they would
do all along Tom drew that line in the
sand and said we are not extending you
you can play under your contract or you
cannot play
we actually don't care we believe that
Austin Eckler can get the job done
Melvin Gordon we'll see if he balks and
decides to play under this last year of
his contract but I actually respect that
the Chargers have said this they've come
out and just said hey this is where
we're at the season starts tomorrow when
you're listening to this we're not gonna
do this we're not gonna carry this into
the season play or don't play you just
let us know I think right now for me
Matt my question is what is Melvin
Gordon even worth in a trade you have to
pay him if you acquire him Jadeveon
Clowney just went for a third and two
players that are not by any means you
know above average starting caliber
players at Melvin Gordon plays running
back it no matter what you think you
have to be a top three to four guy to
get the kind of money that he's asking
for right now maybe a Tampa calls
I mean maybe but when you look at this
situation I don't think the return
very high and I think the Charger's are
very confident right now where they're
sitting there saying yeah we'll roll
with that clear we've seen his you know
filling work before it's it's very
adequate in our offense so this is a
tough situation for Melvin Gordon
there's no way about it but I just don't
see it clearing up anytime soon if you
think back to of the best running backs
in the NFL over the last five years levy
on bail in Ezekiel Elliott had to
basically hold out and are still not
gonna get the money they wanted to get
so if you're Melvin Gordon I'm sorry
you're not on that level you know maybe
maybe want to just take the money that
you're being offered because if you sit
out and hit free agency you're gonna
lose a year of earning power and I don't
think you'll ever make that up as a
running back I just sorry I don't he's
good he's a good running back he's not
good enough to be able to dictate his
market in my opinion yeah I don't think
he changes the game and he's a good pass
catcher but he doesn't change the game
the way McCaffrey is right now say Quan
even David Johnson to an extent
obviously Gurley cámara
that's a eagle Elliot that's a lot of
guys ahead of him right now where you're
sitting there saying man can we make him
the highest-paid running back right now
Tom telesco is a good GM smart GM a team
has run very well a team that doesn't
always have necessarily the finances to
do a lot of different things it's a very
well-run football team that does draft
pretty well and they're drawn their line
in the sand in this situation so one
move they happen over the weekend mellow
and I briefly touched on it on the show
that came out Tuesday morning but we all
wanted to get your opinion so my guy my
guy Malik Jefferson got cut too so it
was a bad weekend for stick to football
guys jumped on a table for but Jakaya
polite gets cut and this is notable for
a couple reasons your Jets fan this is
also a player that you really liked in
the process
and now polite new front office so
that's important Joe Douglas comes in
and Jake Hyppolite is shown the door and
showing it off for being fined over
$100,000 by the team for being late to
meetings you're missing workouts it's
just a bad look for a guy who on tape
there were so many flashes it's an awful
look there's a lot of places you know
did a lot of things to discuss with this
and I'll start with the first one is I
mean I'll be the first to own a miss
things do not look good for Jakaya
polite right now
this is somebody where before the
combine I had him in the top 20 and his
combine and character issues were so bad
I dropped him all the way down to 40
behind players like chase win a [ __ ]
behind rashon Garry obviously behind a
lot of other players whether that was
Josh Allen Brian burns Nick Bosa all of
those pass rushers jumped ahead him in
and ahead of him for me on my rankings
and you know how much I liked him Matt
so that's how bad the character concerns
were now with that being said I know you
and I felt like he was worth a swing for
the fences in the third round this has
been clearly a disaster it shows that
you can't just coast on Talent in the
NFL I think Jake Hyppolite is not
committed to football at the NFL level
and right now it looks like a clear miss
when you put an early second-round grade
on a guy like I did he gets taken in the
third and doesn't even make it through a
full rookie season it's bad it's really
bad
now the second layer of this what went
on in that building because a lot of
people are wondering this is what it
comes down to there was a different
regime running that draft Mike mechag
ninh and Adam GaSe Adam gates in that
worm they stuck up for this player they
felt like he was worth taking the gamble
on the defensive staff that's there Greg
Williams and those guys they didn't want
the player a new GM comes in new GM is
probably listening to that defensive
staff and says look at how bad he's been
this summer I told you so they're not
committing to developing this player
Matt and that's you know what you could
feel whatever way about that I feel like
Jake Hyppolite it was a mix of two
things one it's his fall he doesn't
deserve the excuses but number two it's
not like a Seattle that's gonna work
with this guy in the practice squad and
say hey he has the traits right if we
can get the character in the right place
things will work out Greg Williams isn't
doing that [ __ ] he's not now whether you
agree with that or not is another thing
but it's as simple as that the defensive
staff did not want the player Adam GaSe
in an old regime did a new regime comes
in and they're saying we're moving on
right now so it's a shame it really is
when you have that much talent you're
jukai polite and you just simply cannot
get it together what a disastrous seven
or eight months it's been for him and I
think this goes back to one thing that
that we've talked about a lot this
podcast has been in existence for about
two and a half years it's so hard to
evaluate the off field and Eve
what's your kind play I told this story
on the show that came out Tuesday
morning the first notes I ever put down
for him were character problems immature
bad work ethic and you know that so like
you've been told that and it's like why
and I'm guilty of this too like you let
yourself get fooled by the talent when
you know the guy who's not accountable
and so if there's a lesson to be learned
on my side of this it's trust your
sources and your instincts when it comes
to a player not being reliable not being
consistent like work ethic man that's
like if you're if you're a florida and
you have a bad work ethic it's hard for
me to believe that's just gonna flip
once you get to the NFL and you're
suddenly gonna be you know mr.
johnny-on-the-spot every morning want to
work your ass off so I knew that you
wanted to talk about Jakaya polite I
knew our amazing stickies wanted to hear
from you on it so it'll be interesting
to see that the worst part for the jet
sees third-round picks are supposed to
contribute third-round picks should be
starters in a couple years it's like
that's that's what sucks is that mic
mechanic took a dude that is now a free
agent a couple months later and you
don't have a third-round pick like
that's the hard part because you would
expect a third round to be a building
block this is like one of my pet topics
when I do radio in San Francisco right
now is the CJ Beathard is the number
three quarterback and he was the third
round pick like that that's such a
valuable pick that you wasted on those
you got a hit on the third rounders I
mean they're hoping that their fifth
round or Blake Cashman can be an
adequate starter this year and he better
be because now you're already down a
third rounder you didn't have a second
rounder and you know to Madoka their
other third rounders it's been really
good this summer actually in reserve
reps but he's not starting so at the end
of the day Blake Cashman better pan out
because Chicago pelea was a giant swing
and Miss thank God Quinn and Williams
look so good yeah I mean Quinn didn't
save us that's all you could say at this
point and he will that beautiful braces
smile it'll save us kind of one thing
that we had to do today was to go
through all the moves because even in
the amount of time Melo and I spent on
this Tuesday morning there was not
enough time to truly break down all the
moves that happen over the weekend so
we're gonna put some grades on these
not talked about like all the season
impact but grading the trades because I
know that's what everyone wants to see
from us this morning so let's start here
Jadeveon Clowney traded to the Seattle
Seahawks for nothing basically a third
feels like EVs Mingo and Jacob Martin I
am giving this a solid B for Seattle the
only reason I'm giving it a B is this
will be a push if they cannot sign him
to a long-term extension because he will
then go somewhere else and they will get
a 2021 compensatory pick that will
probably be a third rounder so worst
case scenario this is a one-year rental
and a push for Seattle but I do think
this is a team that like to compete in
their own division I would have probably
tried to lock him up long term
beforehand yeah that would have been
nice obviously you know unfortunately
that couldn't happen as part of the deal
but whoa I mean talk about a low return
here Matt Seattle gets a really really
good football player one of the best run
defenders in the NFL and they've been a
little banged up on the edge this summer
where they actually had to fill this
need and they go out and get the best
guy on the market to do that so for
Seattle it's an a for me you know they
really didn't give up much return I
think clowny fits their scheme perfectly
he sounds excited and rejuvenated to
play in that scheme you look at on the
other side of this for Houston folks
this is what happens when you don't have
a GM running the football team and
listen am I surprised that the return
was this low no because it got to this
point of the season right now the
problem was and they tried to do this
but they failed they should have moved
cloudy before the draft gotten more ammo
and went up for an offensive tackle
names
andre Dillard in this class so they
didn't have to give up their next two
drafts for a great player Laremy Tunsil
and we're gonna get into that trade but
the way they played the clowny situation
is an F yeah it's an F for me as well
and to move a player of that caliber and
only get back at third and to throw away
players because I do know that there
were conversations before the draft
where teams were talking about a package
that would be like a second a fourth and
a sixth so now you get a third and two
guys who are just okay like there's
there not much to write home about
so it's just a bad look and like you
said this is why you need a general
manager
but then Houston does this they trade to
add Laremy Tunsil to this roster and
they they got Kenny Stills as part of it
I want to break those down as basically
separate moves so Tunsil goes to Houston
I have not been shy about saying I think
he's the best young left tackle in
football give it a year - he's the best
left tackle in football and Houston paid
Aloha a first-round pick of 2020 as well
as a first and second in 2021 so they
gave up a lot they gave up more this
Chicago gave up to get Khalil Mack think
about it that way they also do not
negotiate with him on an extension
before executing this trade so that
that's a big part of this as well I'm
gonna give Houston and a - because they
landed Laremy Tunsil who I absolutely
love and this is a gigantic need now I
will say a left tackle doesn't fix all
your offensive line problems they still
need guys like Titus Howard to play good
football
they still need Nick Martin to play good
football so Laremy Tunsil is great he
doesn't solve all your problems Houston
but if I'm to Shawn Watson I at least
feel held a lot better today that they
are trying to protect my ass this year
yeah I'm with you there I think you know
this moves obviously Mack scharping is
gonna play guard he's obviously seen
reps there this summer they have a crazy
preacher just throwing away draft picks
over there there he's not your best I
mean what else can you say it's a quite
a turn of events at the GM spot but now
I know he's done a lot of great work in
New England I just think it is a very
unorthodox way to run a football team
now to the point of the trade
it's a b-plus for me I love Laremy
Tunsil I do think he's the best young
offensive tackle in football they paid
the price Matt I mean this is some
serious ammo where you're gonna have to
get creative to build out the rest of
the football team
I think the acquisition of tons elizabe
plus I think the acquisition of Kenny
Stills is a b-plus they have speed four
days at wide receiver where deshaun
Watson is gonna be airing this thing out
vertically but it's you know once again
they need to get a football mind in
there to capitalize on later around
draft picks in the next couple years
because that's all they'll be working
with at the end of the day though if
this team wins the division and deshaun
Watson is
have to upright and healthy and an MVP
candidate which we believe he could be
everybody will be looking back at this
trade as the difference maker for the
Texans yeah I give it an a-minus can't
remember I said better knock so there's
so many notes because of all the details
these trades all right let's say Kenny
Stills he comes over as a part of a
package to this deal and I was surprised
for a number of reasons that he went to
Houston he's a player who's been
outspoken about social issues we sold to
Wayne Brown leave Houston for the
Seattle Seahawks because of his him
being upset with some of the comments
that the owner of the Houston Texans
made that Kenny Stills leaves Miami very
upset with Steven Ross upset with Brian
Flores it comes to Houston so he gets a
fresh start
I like Kenny Stills a lot I think he's a
good number to a good number three
receiver if will fuller is hurt again
something we've seen happen a lot Kenny
Stills is gonna be a very good option
for them over the middle of the field I
give this an a to get Kenny Stills as
part of this package he's an instant
impact contributor he could be a 50
catch guy for the Houston Texans and
again with so much doubt and uncertainty
about will fuller having Kenny to work
with DeAndre Hopkins is gonna be huge
for deshaun Watson I agree that speed in
that offense that Kenny still spring
that's that's quite the throwing kind of
player I think he's been hampered by the
quarterback play in Miami or even the
scheme at times now speaking of those
Miami Dolphins this is a huge move for
them this is a we're going full rebuild
kind of move you give up a young player
the Tunsil part of it I give it a see I
like the return my biggest issue here is
Matt everyone's talking about well
they're rebuilding they're gonna have a
new quarterback in there soon who is
protecting whoever this new quarterback
is you could you you know obviously open
a huge hole here at offensive tackle I
think what I liked about Miami's rebuild
is that assuming they're gonna take a
quarterback in the top five top ten next
year whether it's Justin Herber to a
tongue of I lower you felt that guy was
gonna have adequate protection on the
left side now you don't maybe they have
a creative you know step two in this
process to figure that out so it's a see
the tanzil part of the trade great
return
huge question mark getting rid of stills
is a B because I think Brian Flores has
come in very similar to Matt Patricia
where it's his way or the highway and I
think there was clear friction there
between him and Kenny Stills and you
want to kind of you know get rid of
those situations before the season even
starts as much as I like the player I
really do I just don't think this was a
situation that was gonna get better
anytime soon I gave my a me a D on the
tonsil trade just because like you said
it's well those things oh you can you
can have all the pics you still gonna
make you got to make the right picks you
got to get the right players to go with
that so we'll see what happens I think
it's it's really a bad team-building
philosophy to trade one of the best
young players that meets you it's
impossibly me to find ya I mean it's one
of the top three positions in football
and you just traded a 25 year-old rock
star so I don't like that move I gave
him a B for moving stills to Houston I
do agree they needed to unload him he
just was not happy with the situation
there and that I don't disagree with him
I'm actually okay with him not being
happy with how things were going there
on and off the field so I I do think
getting something for stills and making
him part of a big package here smart and
really we are gonna talk so much about
the Miami Dolphins for the next two
years because they currently I mean they
own the draft really the next year who
years so it'll be like how Oakland was
this past new Raiders yeah when the old
Browns right exactly so let's move on
LeSean McCoy signs with the Kansas City
Chiefs she was released by the bills
because Frank Gore in general saying its
Singletary are going to be the the guys
there so shady goes to Kansas City
reunited with Andy Reed someone he had a
ton of success with back in Philadelphia
I'm gonna give this a b-minus I felt
like this was I understand the nostalgia
of getting LeSean McCoy there I don't
know that this was where I would spend
money if I were Brett Beach because
Jamie and Williams has looked good
Darwyn Thompson has looked good this did
allow Kansas City to trade Carlos Hyde
to Houston he was really on the outs
anyway on this roster so I I understand
it and I'm excited to see if LaShawn
still looks as good in space as he used
to because Andy is great at getting guys
you know touches out in the flats
just in the run game but I just I feel
like this is a guy who's a little bit
over the hill it's Abby for me the
injuries and the lack of you know he's
not shady right he's not a shady of old
at least he wasn't last year with that
being said I think he'll be a little
rejuvenated being back with Andy Reid I
think having a guy named Pat mahomes
there and all those speedy receiving
targets and Travis Kelce clearing out
space is gonna be a difference maker so
it's a beef for me I don't love
necessarily the money but I do think
we're gonna see some classic LeSean
McCoy games this year because of the
offense because of how whole feed that
feel there he even said he said this he
knows where I wanted to God and want to
go all the way to the west coast I have
relationship but Andy so for the Chiefs
to me it really does create an answer at
least for now at the running back
position
yeah and it's almost like they've
decided they're just not gonna be able
to stop anyone in terms of the defensive
secondary the front seven should be
really good they'll score sixty points a
game we're gonna score 70 take the city
all year yeah the big 12 Chiefs no joke
two moves we mentioned one earlier allow
collars resize with Dallas I'm giving
this an a I love that the Cowboys are
not only making themselves money that
they're gonna use to sign Zeke but the
fact that they are rewarding guys who
fell in the draft
Lyla Collins is a one of I would say
he's like a top four or five right
tackle so to get him locked up for five
more seasons it's really really smart
for Dallas and he fits their identity
somebody that's gonna maul somebody
that's gonna punch you in the face and
probably throw you ten yards down the
field in the run game so he can get out
in front that Zeke do assuming that
thing gets closed hopefully by the time
you're listening to the show we'll see
it's dragged out a lot longer than
anyone expected Lyle Collins getting him
done right now at that price I think
it's an A as well one more extension
comes in here man Chris Ballard wastes
no time right Matt Chico brother set
yeah it's two years on the deal you know
he gets I think 20 million guaranteed so
this to me is an a-minus because yeah
you add some risk in case he's just
awful this year which I don't think
he'll be I actually am a big Jacobi
percent fan then you've added on some
money where I go boy but it's an a-minus
because I'm a believer in him it's not
crazy
I like that the cults are you know for a
player now that has had to wait his turn
while playing well when given the
opportunity it's a confidence booster
you're the guy now you might not be the
guy for the next ten years but you're
getting a legitimate trial here for the
next two to say listen Colts fans I know
you're upset Andrew Luck's gone but I
can play I can win us games in this
division so good for Jacoby percent and
good for the overall culture of the
Colts right now when they need it most
I think that's a huge part of this is
Chris Ballard who knew that the Colts
had the most salary cap of eight space
available of any team says you know what
I'm going to show that I believe in my
guy and that for the next two years he's
going to be with us and to give him 30
million dollars over those two years
that's like jacobi percent was not a
high draft pick he has not been making a
ton of money now he's making starting
quarterback money so I really like this
four percent I think he's gonna be good
I really do so I'm giving that pick
excuse me that extension and a Conor
let's take a break when we come back our
NFL Draft week one wrap up some
takeaways and also your baby
hashtag defense for Heisman a big part
of this show is covering the NFL draft
that's how we started that as our bread
and butter and so every week we're gonna
try to take you through what we saw over
the past weekend well and also on some
shows look ahead to scouting matchups
we'll be watching but let's look at week
one of college football is in the books
there were so many games it almost
became impossible to keep track of I
want to start with the game have a
Monday night I was very excited to see
what Notre Dame pass rusher Julia no
quarrel would do against a Louisville
team that I knew they'd be tougher this
year but Louisville was awful last year
I mean they were embarrassingly well
blessed bottomed out and they quit on so
many games last year I expected okura to
come in and dominate this game just own
this offensive line he didn't he was
pretty quiet and I know like they were
rotating him in a lot and that's just
that's what Notre Dame does you know one
of the first things that that jumped out
to me was watching it or seeing him sick
damage he's so well built he's six for
250 he looks the part and he did have a
sack last night but I just didn't see
the domination from him and I don't want
to overreact these
not like week one like oh my god this
players gonna go undrafted
I still think Oh Quora is a first round
player I just expected a little bit more
out of him last night and maybe that
speaks to Louisville and how different
they look under Scott Satterfield but
this was not the the marquee game I was
really thinking that he would have those
are definitely the kind of games you
look back on you go wow Louisville was
actually just that much better or you
look back and go on man this guy
underachieved in that game so it no
overreactions but definitely a very
noteworthy reaction for me it starts
with from your favorite Oklahoma sooner
team here Matt Charleston Rambo this
name number one is just phenomenal but
that breakaway speed was eye-opening and
I have to give a shout out his Instagram
name is ball out charlie
that is the best Instagram name when
your name is Charleston and your last
name is Rambo so the Rambo man four oh
you
I mean we're there you know we're expect
CD lamb to be you know quite the player
this year but there's gonna be some
other targets from now Heisman favorite
Jalen hurts so a great game from
Charleston Rambo well and that's who's
next on my list is Jalen hurts a player
that I know that I was like man I just
you know he wasn't that good at Oklahoma
as a passer and you and Melo were both
like his Lincoln Riley I would just wait
and see
and I do want to say they played Houston
they don't play defense in Houston so we
got away knows what happens once he
plays a real cover though they did cover
that's all that matters but my god Jalen
Hertz looked amazing six touchdowns in
his debut with the ease that's a record
in Oklahoma where they've had some
amazing players so I am on the Jalen
Hertz wagon he was just so good he
really was and I think as a as a draft
prospect I am intrigued and I was
actually i was doing radio last week and
someone asked me about Jalen Hurd so
it's like listen he's over 21 years old
he's barely 21 years old he just turned
21 earlier in August there's a lot of
development left for him and he's an
exceptional leader he's an exceptional
athlete I don't want to discount
anything when it comes to Jalen Hurd so
when it comes to Hertz and the NFL Draft
I'm excited to see where this season
takes him me too I mean
just the fact that we might get to see
him in mobile this year I know our our
buddy Jim and Aggie would be pretty
happy about that and I think when it
comes down to it he's now in a system
where guys flourish and it's a system
where Lincoln Riley takes in the guys
that have been afterthoughts somewhere
else and then they go on to win the
Heisman and then they go on to go number
one overall I don't think Jalen Hurd's
is going number one overall but we're
talking about a player where two years
ago we're like oh he's a running back
and now we're sitting here and going man
maybe he could be a pity round
quarterback [ __ ] so good for Jalen Hertz
and man is he pissed off after that game
somebody that doesn't have their eyes
set on stats or cupcake wins he has
somebody this is someone that said on a
championship and probably feels you know
feel some kind of way after not being
the guide Alabama anymore
speaking of Alabama probably going to be
their toughest opponent this year those
Georgia Bulldogs I was in Nashville
those Georgia fans were running around
everywhere that fan base travels so well
so shout out to them the combo of Andrew
Thomas who I think is the best offensive
lineman in the country and the running
back that I think is the best running
back in the country and DeAndre Swift
there was one play to the outside for
man at least at probably 20 yards Thomas
gets out so fast and upfield makes his
block seals that outside Swift is gone
Thomas puts his head down like he's
running the 40-yard dash I love these
guys I think they play a different kind
of way at the NFL really at an NFL level
where Swift can run by you make you miss
he'll run through you Thomas is gonna
I'm already gonna say it Matt he's gonna
get the Jonah Williams always sick for
short arms I don't give a [ __ ] he's a
great player no he is a great player I
know Melo has said he's his top tackle
he's my top tackle sounds like he's
gonna be your top tackle guess what he's
just really really good John Drake Swift
was so physical in this game to say you
think of him it's like oh this he's kind
of fast you know he's this athletic back
I've compared him to Alvin Kamara
because he will put you in the dirt and
he'll run by you like he's so special as
a prospect my last one
I'm actually
that disappointed me and and here's what
I wanted to about Kelly Bryant
there's a reason Clemson wanted to move
this dude to receiver there's a reason
NFL teams believe he will move to
receiver Missouri couldn't beat Wyoming
they could do nothing offensively Bryant
played he had a huge fumble that really
turned this game around I know people
are gonna look and say but he threw for
423 yards and threw for two touchdowns
this was an ugly performance by Kelly
Bryant and in offense that should be
really tailored to what he does well so
again we're not overreacting to week one
but there's a reason that the NFL was so
down on Kelly Bryant that they were
asking him to move to wide receiver my
last one is Lynn Bowden I know he made
our preview for the SEC this year very
briefly because of how phenomenal of a
special teams player he is but a nice
receiving debut and I'm starting to get
the feeling what batten when teams go
back and watch the film they're gonna
realize he's a little limited by the
quarterback play at times if you're just
getting the ball in his hands he's gonna
create plays he's gonna get yards he's
gonna add special teams values so in a
crowded wide receiver crop where Judy CD
Lam T Higgins ylvis' Kishin all and even
Henry Rose those guys are dominating the
scene somebody like Bowden someone like
Tyler Vaughn's at USC I think they
deserve a little more love in this group
and it's exciting to see them get off to
a fast start yeah it is it is fun to
look at some of these there's so many
good receivers that you just we don't
have time to talk about all of them we
almost need to do a damn receiver show
let's transition though to defense this
is your baby
defense for Heisman and we both way big
tin pass rusher it was just that kind of
women not Penn State absolutely
dominated 79 to 7 over Idaho and our guy
leader grosse Meadows went off he
currently leads all of college football
in sacks which is what you would expect
maybe after playing Idaho two and a half
sacks for my man six-five 265 I've
already said he looks like a filled out
Brian burns to me so he could be a top
15 pick after this season but if we're
talking Heisman Trophy no.1 in college
football in my opinion deserves more
mention defensively than growth made us
I'm gonna say not so fast and this was
your prediction for
number one overall pick mr. chase young
has something to say about that my
goodness this was the week one Nick Bosa
against Oregon State game all over again
and if you're a Buckeyes fan you know
exactly what I'm talking about
chase young could simply not be blocked
against FAU and I know you're gonna sit
there and say oh it's FAU
I don't care he doesn't control who he
plays against and he plays very well
against good teams to one and a half
sacks he was more impressive than what
the stat line says they tried doubling
him they tried chipping him he ran
through people he ran around people he
does such a good job keeping up you know
offensive lineman's hands away from him
that bursts that explosiveness he's
gigantic now I thought he looked not
thin last year or two years ago but he
looked like he had some filling out to
do yeah check mark so chase young
hashtag defense for Heisman week 1 of
the NFL season is finally here tomorrow
night Thursday night if your hopefully
listening to this Wednesday morning the
games will be kicking off Connor let's
rip through these buddy pick a weak one
against the spread Green Bay Packers at
Chicago Bears this is a Thursday night
game the Bears are favored minus three
over under is 46 I'm gonna take the
Bears but I'm telling you take the under
in this one I think this Bears defense
is just too good I think I just have
wishful thinking by taking the over in
this one I want to see a shootout for
this NFL kickoff here Matt it's it's a
toss-up on this one I'll take the over
for fun I think the Packers cover I
think it's gonna be a really really
close game I think mr. Aaron Rodgers is
gonna come out very very angry being out
of the spotlight so this is a rare one
where we disagree on next up Atlanta
Falcons at Minnesota Vikings that line
is you know obviously tight these are
both very good teams the Vikings have to
- for 47 and 1/2 is the over/under I
take the Falcons to cover this I
actually think the Falcons win this game
but getting four points here is a lot I
know it's cuz they're on the road I know
the Vikings are a good team I'm picking
a bounce-back year for the Falcons and I
got the over in this one as well I'm
with you - I was really surprised by
this line honestly so I'm taking the
Falcons and I'm taking the over on this
one wash
Redskins at Philadelphia Eagles the
Eagles are favored by eight and a half
which is the biggest spread in the
second-biggest spread in all of week one
the over-under is 45 and a half I'm
gonna take the Eagles
I think they win this and I think they
went by double digit points but I am
gonna say to take the under in this
I don't believe Washington can score
enough pointing and I can see
Philadelphia getting a little
conservative late in this one if the
game is wrapped up nailed it right there
Eagles and the under I think the Eagles
are gonna get an early lead and they're
really gonna run the ball Jordan Howard
it's gonna get a lot of work in this one
will get to see Myles Sanders next up
Buffalo Bills coming here to MetLife
Stadium the New York Jets are favored by
three in this game thirty nine and a
half is the the point line there listen
not trying to be a homer I think the
Jets win and cover in this game because
I think Sam Donald is gonna be able to
score points I am taking the under
because I think this is gonna be classic
sloppy bills Jets week one football
where I don't think we're gonna see them
score a ton in this one yeah I'm taking
the under as well I'm gonna take the
bills though I just worry about that jet
secondary a little bit and got a lit up
yes and now the pass rush the outside
pass rush so I am taking the bills in
this one Baltimore Ravens at Miami
Dolphins
it's dolphins plus five the over/under
is 37 and a half making Shh
take it away vans you hate the Ravens
I'm actually gonna take the over because
I think the Ravens just they just put
the points on I think Lamar Jackson just
goes off in this one so I am gonna be
optimistic and take the over
it's the under for me not expecting a
ton of points in this one but enough
here for the Ravens to easily easily
cover that ridiculous point spread put
some respect on Baltimore's name
all right Chiefs at Jacksonville
Jacksonville it's actually obviously the
underdog because we talked about those
big 12 Chiefs they could score but the
Chiefs are only favored by four points
in this game Matt I am real-life betting
on the Chiefs to smash this one out of
the park I think I actually got it at a
line of three and a half originally
which was ridiculous and over on the 52
point over/under so Chiefs over easy
yeah Chiefs in the over on this easy
they might score 52 by themselves and
this one from a
a scouting standpoint I really am
anxious to see because they say jaylen
Rams he's gonna follow Tyree kill I want
to see that because last time that
happened Tyreke went for 60 yards so
that'll be fun to watch Tennessee Titans
at Cleveland Browns this is something we
would not have thought a year ago the
Browns are favored - five and a half the
over-under is 45 and a half I'm taking
the Browns and I'm actually gonna take
the over in this one I don't know the
Titans can score but I know the Browns
can I'm taking the Browns but I'm
actually gonna take the under
I think the Titans are gonna get home
and sack Baker Mayfield a lot in this
game or at least force some turnovers
but the Browns are gonna score enough to
cover and to win yeah man I mean I hope
the Browns live up to it all the hype so
lots of line so what that's the key that
is the key Los Angeles Rams at Carolina
Panthers the Rams - three over under
fifty and a half I'm taking the Rams and
I'm taking the over on the Rams in every
[ __ ] game this year I mean easy easy
easy
same for me Rams over this was my only
other real life bet for week one I
really think the Rams covered this line
it's just that's not a lot of points man
it's not and we see you give Shaun
McVeigh how many months to plan for a
game I think he'll be just fine yeah and
the Panthers I just don't know what
we're gonna see from Cam Newton I really
don't Cincinnati Bengals at Seattle
Seahawks this is the biggest difference
biggest point spread of week one
Seahawks are favored by nine and a half
the over/under is 44
I'm taking the Seahawks and I I put the
over I actually want the under into
something I carried away I'm gonna take
the under I don't think Cincinnati can
score on this defense and that's it for
me this is the exact same argument for
Washington at Philadelphia it's gonna be
the same kind of game Seahawks and the
under the Colts going to Los Angeles to
play those Chargers charters favored by
seven that's a pretty fat number they're
44 points is the over-under at you and I
agree here it's the Chargers it's the
over I know
Colts fans it's disappointing here you
probably were juiced up for week one
they can take a little time to get fully
up to speed there yeah I think so -
we'll see you if Jacobi bracelet did
take all the qb1 reps all offseason
because of Luxx injuries yeah we'll see
what happens but I'm with you I take the
Chargers and the over my team the San
Francisco 49ers go to Tampa Bay the
Buccaneers are favored
- one with an over-under forty nine and
a half the Niners are gonna win this
game number one and they're thrown away
by a lot more than one point but I would
take the under on forty nine and a half
this is very disrespectful
this line I don't care where that green
it could be on Mars at the end of the
day I still don't believe in Jameis
Winston there are a lot of people on
this planet that think every year is
gonna be the year and even if he comes
out and lights up the 49ers defense
I think Kyle Shanahan is gonna have a
field day against you know my old friend
Todd Bowles his defense and Tampa there
I think Nick Bosa has more sex than this
point spread the blinds suck easily
agree I could go in a twenty minute rant
about that one game Detroit Lions at
Arizona Cardinals the Kliff Kingsbury
era gets started the Cardinals excuse me
the Lions are favored - two and a half
the over/under forty seven and a half
I'm taking the Lions
I think Matt Patricia just dominates
this team and I'm taking the under in
this one surprisingly given that it's a
Kliff Kingsbury offense yeah I don't say
a lot of nice things about the mature
Matt Patricia led Lions but at the end
of the day they're gonna win this game
they are gonna cover in this game and
they are probably gonna go under because
right like it's hard to believe in the
Cardinals to really do a lot right now
I'm just gonna be honest
so moving on the Giants at the Cowboys I
think is equal Ellie it'll be back it's
getting a little scary right now folks
but cowboys and the under I think the
Cowboys cover that line of seven they're
seven point favorites there I just don't
think the Giants are gonna be very good
with Eli Manning under center I know
what a world we're talking about hey
bring in Daniel Jones but guess what it
you should be wanting Daniel Jones in
forty five and a half seems really high
for this Giants very high and a Cowboys
team that you know Cooper has been a
little banged up Zeke has been holding
out so I'm gonna take the under but I am
gonna take the Cowboys the game of the
week in my opinion is this one
Pittsburgh Steelers at New England
Patriots the Patriots are favored by six
and fifty one and a half C over/under I
am gonna take the Patriots six is tough
though I wanted I wanted to say take the
Steelers because that's too many points
but I will say take the over in this one
and I did take the Steelers to cover in
this one I think New England wins the
game
I think the Steelers are gonna hang
around obnoxiously I really do it might
be in New England win by a field goal or
four points something along that lines
I just think six is a really really big
line and and I do think this games goes
over like you said Matt this is the game
to watch this is a shootout Houston at
New Orleans another one to watch because
we know what these offenses can do
pretty big lie in the Saints favored by
seven points here 53 and a half is the
over take the over on this one I
actually like the Texans to cover I
think it's a very very close game I do
think the Saints probably win at home
but don't think the Sean wasps is just
gonna lie down he's gonna be firing that
football - the clock runs out I took the
Saints I think they do cover just
because that I don't know about the
Texans defense especially the secondary
I think they could be picked on a little
bit but we need to see Drew Brees look
better than he did the last time we saw
him in the playoff story struggle so I'm
taking the Texans excuse me I'm taking
the Saints and the over the last game
here Denver Broncos at Oakland Raiders
the Raiders are favored - one over
unders 43 I'm gonna take the Raiders I
think they win I think they cover and
I'm gonna take the under on 43 I don't
know the Broncos are gonna score many
points I don't think they will and I
think it's gonna be Raiders in the under
for me as well and I think we're gonna
see a lot of Josh Jacobs in this game
which has us pretty excited the Raiders
they can get up they can run the ball
I'm just not a big believer in Denver in
this game right now so only favored by 1
Oakland actually thought they should
have got the home field advantage line
of at least three points I really like
them in this one me too man me too it's
gonna be a fun week one I'm excited to
get going I'm also excited because as we
into the show here Saturday at 2:30 come
out to pluckers on Rio Grande in Austin
Texas we will be there doing the show
will be there handing out swag handing
out wings handing out cold beverages
2:30 until 5:30 me mel o'connor come see
the show come participate in the show we
might have some special guests even drop
by so it's gonna be a blast I know we're
all excited for the Texas heat in early
September oh dude it's gonna be hot down
there but we're gonna have a great time
can't wait to get the tailgate tour
officially kicked off so you have any
questions send them our way if not your
ass better be at the tailgate tour this
year